organizers had built this second weekend
of the blockade around the canadian
parliament as a family day it's clear
there's an awareness of the negative
headlines of last weekend when
protesters were accused of attacking
those wearing masks and displaying
racist symbols
the blockade began as a protest about
cross-border trucking vaccine mandates
even though 90 percent of cross-border
truckers are vaccinated and the u.s
insists on vaccination too but clearly
it's now about pandemic policy in
general we're fed up with these
restrictions since two years
everywhere locked down curfew
you know what you i mean
and those who joined the protesters on
saturday also raised a range of issues
the protest organizers who are from the
extreme right wing of canadian politics
are demanding the overthrow of the
government but there were also
anti-vaxxers religious fundamentalists
and those raising topics of concern to
both the right and left like the power
of pharmaceutical companies or the civil
liberties implications of mandates and
then there were those who'd simply had
enough of the pandemic everything has
been locked down in person lock down
again
spending like days and weeks in my
bedroom and then going all the way back
to school and still feeling isolated the
polls do show a majority of canadians
are fed up with the handling of the
pandemic by both federal and provincial
authorities but they also show
overwhelming support for mandates and
public health measures designed to ease
the strain on the health care system
and that makes the organizers ultimatum
that they won't budge unless all
mandates are removed challenging
it is difficult to see how this will end
we've covered protests in canada in the
past either for indigenous rights or
against pipelines and the authorities
have cracked down swiftly but these
trucks aren't going to be moved so
easily shia brutality al jazeera ottawa